[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale sur tv soixante dix huit ans ce
vendredi 27 mars édition nouvellement
ans consacrés à la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus dans les yvelines la
pandémie toujours en hausse dans la
région les chiffres liés aux copies de
19 sont même vertigineux en ile de
france comme l'a affirmé ce matin
aurélien rousselot directeur de l'agencé
régionale de santé
près de 1300 personnes sont aujourd'hui
en réanimation pour environ 1500 lits
disponibles dans la région francilienne
environ 200 lits sont encore disponibles
seulement mais plusieurs centaines de
places supplémentaires vont être
ouvertes en réanimation selon la rs
parmi les victimes dans les yvelines nos
confrères du parisien rapporte le décès
de deux autres résidents de l'ehpad le
parc des dames à saint-germain-en-laye
ce qui porte à seize morts le bilan sur
place le groupe korian gestionnaire du
lieu confirment une situation grave dans
cet ehpad
mais ne donne aucun chiffre les
résidents sont désormais soumis à un
confinement strict dans leur chambre
autre disparition liés aux coville 19
celle du père marc phrasé 74 ans curé de
la paroisse est de fontenay-le-fleury il
est décédé dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi après avoir contracté le virus
il ya plusieurs jours marc phrasé et le
premier prêtre à mourir en fonction dans
le département il sera inhumé à chartres
pour tenter d'endiguer cette triste
tendance le confinement a été déclenchée
voici onze jours en france et dans les
yvelines est deux semaines quasiment
après le lancement de cette mesure ont
fait le point sur la situation dans le
département et nicolas quere le vide
c'est nicolas gandrille ont interrogé le
directeur de cabinet du préfet des
yvelines
la situation est à l'image de celle qui
prévaut dans l'ensemble de l'île de
france et une situation préoccupante le
premier ministre a parlé de l'arrivée de
la vague épidémique
c'est effectivement la situation à
laquelle est confrontée l'ensemble de
l'ile-de-france et des yvelines aux 5000
de france n'ont pas ce week-end il y a
un énorme effort dans l'ensemble des
hôpitaux d'île de france et aussi dans
les hôpitaux des yvelines pour augmenter
la capacité d'accueil en particulier en
lits de soins critiques ou en lits de
réanimation l' agence régionale de santé
a fixé un objectif de doublement des
capacités pour la semaine prochaine et
les hôpitaux des yvelines sont en
capacité de faire face à ce défi en
mobilisant toutes les énergies
l'ensemble des hôpitaux à la fois des
hôpitaux publics comme les hôpitaux
privés comme les cliniques qui
participent collectivement à l'effort
c'est un effort très intense mais il ya
une formidable mobilisation de
l'ensemble des équipes médicales
pour relever ce défi du nombre de lits
de réanimation
et puis pas de marché dans les yvelines
ce week-end depuis la décision du
gouvernement début de semaine
d'interdire la tenue de ses marchés la
préfecture des yvelines a reçu 25
demandes de dérogation formulées par les
maires du département aucune n'a été
acceptés sauf pour la commune de château
fort
écoutez les explications de vincent
roberti secrétaire général de la
préfecture
ce n'était pas un marché parce que
c'était un commerce un point de vente
unique sur une place un producteur de
viande en l'occurrence nous regardons
toutes les demandes de dérogation
puisque l'interdiction et nationale des
marchés et les préfets regarde les
dérogations demandées par les maires
et dans ce cadre là nous regardons les
dérogations quand le besoin
d'approvisionnement n'est pas avéré et
que les conditions de sécurité sanitaire
ne sont pas remplies on refuse la dgre
la dérogation
et depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire les hôpitaux des yvelines ont
dû se réadapter un peu plus de 300 lions
ont été affectés pour la prise en charge
des malades du coronavirus 90 patients
hospitalisés à poissy une centaine à
l'hôpital mignot du chesnay rocancourt
est dans ce dernier centre hospitalier
quinze personnes étaient hier en
réanimation
le site compte 24 lits spécifique pour
la réanimation l'équipe dédiée aux tests
des soignants va être renforcée le
personnel hospitalier en première ligne
de cette bataille contre le virus une
situation entendu partout en france et
dans la région
je vous propose d'écouter ce témoignage
le hic josserand est responsable du
service santé publique et épidémiologie
et du groupe hospitalier ile de france
ouest de l'ap-hp un message à passer
respectez le confinement celui qui est
également vice doyen de l'ufr des
sciences de la santé de l'université
versailles à saint quentin nous parle du
renfort des étudiants cette période la
situation est largement décrite décrite
par ailleurs donc effectivement c'est je
vais pas me dire que c'est simple au
niveau des hôpitaux je pense que là c
est sacré vous raconter n'importe quoi
les équipements sous tension le message
qu'il faut je pense continuer à faire
passer et marconnet s'est effectivement
il faut que tout le monde reste bien
qu'elle soit pourquoi l'attention de
façon à éviter les contaminations parce
que ce dont on peut se comprendre c'est
que les contaminations vont très vite
donc il faut vraiment être extrêmement
aidant dans ce comportement est adoptée
tous les gestes barrière de parce qu'on
se protéger soi même mais également
protéger les autres c'est important ça
marche dans les deux sens
faut vraiment avoir une notion là se
protéger mais quand on se protège on
protège également les zones donc ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'essentiel
à retenir quoi et plus les gens se
protégeront qui est moins la pression
sur le système hospitalier traqueront et
ça aussi c'est important puisqu'on sait
très bien que moins de gens vont se
retrouver à l'hôpital et plus dont
pourra prendre les gens en charge de
façon convenable et sans aucune
difficulté
c'est ça qu'il faut retenir donc surtout
se protéger pour ne pas finir à la fois
les mesures du type le mans c'est de
placer la france en confinement ça s'est
épris s'il mesure qui est
à la hauteur en tout cas pour pour
lutter efficacement contre la
propagation du virus est une mesure
c'est une mesure indispensable inédite
pense que personne en france l'imaginer
ça il ya encore trois semaines ou un
mois
mais c'est une mesure qui est à la
hauteur des dangers aujourd'hui parce
qu'on a on se rencontre en conséquent
les pays ne sont pas et qui n'ont pas
pris ses précautions en a aujourd'hui
son temps sont en difficulté alors je
parle pas de l'italie et de l'espagne ce
qu'on voit que peut donc des mesures
mais qui malheureusement en efficacité
n'inquiète pas été au bout on est sain
il ya peut-être à l'arraché pour 15
jours mais qu'en est il chez un des pays
qui ont retardé à prendre des mesures d'
angleterre par exemple vont avoir à
faire face à des adhérents à la une a
une incidence est bien largement
supérieure à celle qu'on va rencontrer
des états unis où c'est en train de
démarrer en flash également
je pense que ces mesures étaient
absolument indispensable ne pas les
prendre et est suicidaire on l'a compris
un pourront aussi aider le personnel
soignant qui est totalement engagé dans
cette crise le personnel soignant qui
est aussi un besoin de deux renforts ya
les étudiants en médecine notamment qui
viennent en aide à ce personnel soignant
est ce que des étudiants du vécu je
rappelle que vous êtes vice doyen de
l'ufr de santé des sciences de la santé
lui est ce qu est ce que des étudiants
de l'ueh rescue prêtent main forte au
personnel soignant l'enseignement et des
étudiants prêtent main forte au
personnel soignant bien évidemment ce
tronçon de nos futurs professionnels de
santé donc c'est tout à fait normal
qu'ils puissent qu'ils puissent
participer à cet effort
il ya différentes façons de le faire
effectivement il ya dans les services
quand on est très directement imaginé il
ya d'autres il ya d'autres solutions qui
existent notamment à bobigny d'un
certain nombre d'études en médecine sur
une nouvelle plate-forme de réponse
téléphonique a été mise en place par
l'ap-hp l'assistance des hôpitaux de
paris et qui pour éviter justement la
surcharge hospitalière la surcharge et
médecins libéraux répond enregistré un
cercle d'amis services d'urgence quand
il voit passer qu'un temps qui est
susceptible d'être d'être positif et qui
présente la symptomatologie du coc vide
ces gens sont convaincus sur sur une
plate sur une application le médecin et
rentrer sur l'application et ensuite ils
sont suivis à distance via cette
application pas
ddd des consultants qui sont donc qui
peuvent être des étudiants des
infirmières est organisée en cellules et
chaque cellule est supervisé par un
médecin donc c'est on évite à travers ce
système a déjà anglès les gens à la
maison ça évite de surcharger les
hôpitaux
la vie me suis chargé des portions de
deux médecins généralistes a dit aux
gens de sortir et d'aller voir des
médailles dans l'armée des croisés les
gens me font passer avant d'aller dans
des salles d'accord vient donc de
limiter les contacts et donc éviter les
contaminations
ça c'est extrêmement important et
surtout un point essentiel c'est céline
ça rassure ça rassure énormément les
patients de se savoir surveiller à
distance il remplit seul un petit
questionnaire deux fois par jour sur une
application et un petit niveau dallaire
et enfin franck ni coderre on rappelle
des gens des gens qui m'ont bien n'y a
pas de raison dérapé en revanche les
gens qui présentent une altération de
leur santé ou on les rappelle ont fait
le point avec eux et si il faut qu'on
appelle le samu ou indirectement qu'on a
la chance d'avoir une vie d'après
déchets avec les différents sam et ile
de france
et bien merci le exaucera nous avoir
accordé le grand clint et bon courage à
vous merci au revoir je voulais juste de
rajouter qu il allait effectivement le
personnel soignant en parle on en parle
beaucoup mais il ya beaucoup de gens
travaillent à l'hôpital n'y a pas que du
personnel à suivre donc ça faut pas
l'oublier et il ya aussi beaucoup de
gens en dehors de l'hôpital qui
travaillent qui continuent à travailler
ils permettent aussi aux personnels
soignants continuer à tourner c'est
aussi important à l'avoir en tête
tout le monde est important à condition
de bien respecter les mesures barrières
le pic de la pandémie est attendue pour
les prochains jours en ile de france
pour faire face à l'afflux de malades et
à l' angoisse des habitants les médecins
de ville s'organise dans les yvelines
plusieurs centres dédiés aux qu'ovide 19
ont été ouverts cette semaine à poissy
comme vous le voyez sur ces images
tournées au centre de diffusion
artistique qui a été réaménagé
mais aussi à saint germain en laye ou
encore aux chaînés rocancourt ces
centres permettent de recevoir à
proximité des hôpitaux des patients
qu'ils pensent être contaminée qui
présentent des symptômes bénins
écoutez à ce propos le président du
conseil de l'ordre des médecins des
yvelines
interrogé par mélanie poké et nicolas
kirillovitch
[Musique]
le rôle de la médecine de ville
c'est de pouvoir dans un premier temps
on recevoir les gens qui le demande qui
sont suspect de covile c'est à dire
qu'ils ont quelques symptômes pouvant
évoquer un co vide et pour éviter de
faire croiser des populations au sein
des cabinets on leur dit d'aller en
préférence dans ces centres dédiés par
régulation par le 15 et par leur médecin
traitant
c'est à dire que vous appelez la
population appelle son médecin traitant
lui décrivent s'est décrit ses symptômes
et le médecin traitant dit bah oui je
peux vous recevoir parce que je pense
qu'il n'ya aucun souci ou non je préfère
pas vous recevoir je préfère vous
adresser à ces centres dédiés où on vous
examinera et on fera un diagnostic et en
fonction de ça je vous serez pris en
charge on a commencé par d un centre
dédié à l'hôpital mignot y en a un qui
s'est ouvert sur l'hôpital de saint
germain
mais c'est des locaux isolé par rapport
au reste de l'hôpital généralement et
puis par exemple à poissy ça n'a rien à
voir avec l'hôpital même si c'est un 150
m là c'est le maire qui a offert le
gymnase qui l'a équipé qu'il a organisée
avec les médecins de poissy et la
consultation se fera à ce niveau là
[Musique]
on a eu un message un peu complexes de
notre premier ministre qui nous a dit
vous ne pouvez plus allez consulter
votre médecin et je crois que ça c'est
pas possible il ya d'autres pathologies
qui doivent avoir plus en charge par la
médecine de ville
donc pour sécuriser les circuits on
oriente plutôt les médecins
potentiellement qu'ovide positif vers
des centres dédiés comme sa plus grande
sécurité
les autres malades pour d'autres
pathologies peuvent aller dans les
cabinets médicaux on a cinq qui sont
vraiment opérationnels et puis d'autres
qui sont le but c'est de couvrir tout le
territoire du département 78 je crois
que pour ça on a fait avec grâce avec
l'action de la rs des milieux
hospitaliers où on a une coordination
parfaite
on est en train d'organiser l'ensemble
du territoire du soixante dix huit pour
pouvoir répondre à toute la population
[Musique]
je vais prendre l'exemple de millions
qui a été un des premiers centres
ouverts avec le trille l on a ouvert
l'agenda le dimanche dans la journée le
lundi il y avait déjà 15 de
consultations de patients le mardi
c'était plein et donc on va s'adapter
c'est à dire que pour l'instant on est
simplement un médecin par toutes les
trois heures
messi a besoin on est en capacité de
doubler les effectifs ou même de les
tripler au cas où pendant le confinement
ce sont aussi les services de secours
qui sont pleinement mobilisées dans le
département à commencer par les sapeurs
pompiers qui depuis le début de la crise
sont intervenus près de 1300 fois en
lien avec le coronavirus pour compléter
le dispositif opérationnel trois
ambulances supplémentaires sont venues
et garnir les rangs du sdiss 78è les
pompiers qui malgré le contexte réalise
toujours leurs missions premières tout
en assurant la protection la sécurité de
ses personnels et l'accompagnement des
agents touché plusieurs cas de covin 19
se sont déclarés chez les pompiers des
yvelines
ils ont tous été mis à l'isolément et ne
présente pour l'heure aucun symptôme
aggrave en renfort des effectifs de
garde du samu 60,18 les bénévoles de la
protection civile des yvelines également
engagé une quarantaine est mobilisé en
ce moment dans le département
l'objectif est de monter entre cinq et
dix gardes en avril la protection civile
a aussi dépêché deux personnes 24 heures
sur 24 au centre hospitalier de poissy
saint germain en laye et de françois
quesnay à mantes-la-jolie leur mission
accueillir et orienter les personnes sur
place
c'est un acteur majeur de l'action
sociale et du secourisme la croix rouge
est pleinement engagée en ce moment aide
aux plus démunis soutien des missions du
samu et renfort auprès des centres
hospitaliers elle est détaillée les
précisions de l'activité dans cet
entretien a mené par mélanie poker
cédric robert bonjour vous êtes le
coordinateur de l'opération covit pour
la croix rouge 78 quelles sont vos
activités aujourd'hui en coin de
pandémie alors la preuve d un française
des yvelines a été mon billet
une dizaine de jours sur cette
coopération qu'ovide 19 au travers de
différentes actions alors au quotidien
on assure déjà des activités d'action
sociale qu'on nous avons revu réaménagé
pour mettre en place des protections
pour nos bénéficiaires ou nos bénévoles
donc nous avons maintenu quatre
activités principales au niveau de
l'action sociale qui sont la
domiciliation l'aide alimentaire
l'accueil de jour et les maraudes donc
compenser une activité avec bien entendu
des mesures bien particulière qui sont
mis en place pour protéger les
bénéficiaires et les bénévoles
on a aussi depuis une dizaine de jours
renforcer le samu avec un appui sur la
cellule téléphonique du samu notamment
sur la gestion de sms et est depuis une
dizaine de jours on met à disposition
une ambulance de 8 heures le matin
jusqu'à minuit qui fait du coc vide qui
part à domicile pour faire une prise en
charge de cas suspect qu'on vide
en plus de ça on a également mis à
disposition de véhicules et jets avec de
secouriste à bord de chaque véhicule qui
vont faire de la levée de doute et de
l'évaluation à domicile donc pour faire
un bilan primaire secouriste qui est
retransmis au médecin régulateur du samu
et en fonction de un des symptômes
excita le médecin l'a décidé si cela
nécessite une évacuation sur un centre
hospitalier où si la personne que rester
à domicile c'est un c'est un
moyen de soulager les urgences les
appelle le samu j'imagine oui tout à
fait alors depuis dijon le nombre
d'appels au samu exploser des des
chiffres qu'on n'avait jamais vu
voilà au niveau des centres d'appels
donc ça a permis de les soulager de
prendre le temps de se réorganiser aussi
donc c'était quelque chose d'essentiel
et la croix-rouge avait toute sa place
dans cette mission auprès du siamu
également aussi depuis trois jours nous
renforçons les urgences de l'hôpital
mignon où nous mettons à disposition des
secouristes mais également des étudiants
infirmiers de notre institut un fermier
à mantes la jolie
du coup qu'ils n'ont plus écoles et du
coup il renforce aussi les urgences de
l'hôpital de mignot avec des secouristes
pour prendre en charge toutes les
personnes suspectes du colis de 19 avec
une tante qui a été mis en
la seconde salle des urgences j'imagine
que c'est un grand nombre de bénévoles
qui ont été sollicités tout à fait c'est
à peu près de 100 bénévoles tous les
jours sont mobilisés dans le cadre de
cette opération de ce soit pour
maintenir nos actions sociales pas s'il
faut pas oublier l'ensemble de nos
bénéficiaires contre en charge au
quotidien
il faut qu'ils puissent continuer à se
nourrir à pouvoir récupérer leur
courrier au niveau des domiciliations
donc il ya des personnes qui continue
ses actions sociales et puis toutes les
bénévoles qui sont engagés le
principalement sur des missions
spécifiques au vide comme aux seins nus
comme aux urgences et pour être complet
sur ce sujet la croix rouge a mis en
place le dispositif croix rouge chez
vous un numéro de téléphone dédié aux
personnes isolées dans l'incapacité de
sortir de chez elle l'objectif de cette
plateforme permettre la livraison de
produits de première nécessité et des
médicaments sur ordonnance et maintenir
le lien social
en discutant avec des bénévoles de la
croix-rouge et pour refermer cette
thématique dédié au personnel soignant
et aux personnels de secours la
solidarité de plusieurs yvelinois
s'observe en ce moment comme partout en
france vous l'avez vu des
applaudissements
chaque soir à 20h des chefs aussi qui
concocte des plats pour les hôpitaux et
nous vous parlions en cette semaine de
l'initiative du maure pas y un jean
christophe broux dit il à a livré hier
ses premiers repas gastronomique au
service à néonatalité de l'hôpital
mignot au menu feuilleter saint jacques
poêlées de légumes lorrain à l'huile de
truffe cheese cake ou encore muffins aux
épices de chocolat bon appétit au
personnel soignant est des choses aussi
plus symboliques comme ce choeur avec au
centre un hash signifiant hôpital tracé
dans un champ de rennes moulin l'image a
été captée par mélanie poker et nicolas
kirillovitch enfin dans les initiatives
à pour relayer celle du scg qui est
basée à saint germain en laye dans les
yvelines
le club a mis en vente depuis hier 1500
maillot collector pas de sponsor centre
mais un message tous unis ces pièces
uniques sont vendus au prix de 175 euros
somme intégralement reversés à
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
sachez enfin que si vous souhaitez
apporter votre aide dans cette période
le gouvernement
a lancé un nouveau dispositif
républicain à la réserve civile qu'ovide
objectif permettre à ceux qui le
souhaitent de consacrer du temps aux
plus démunis et plus vulnérables les
missions vont de l'aide alimentaire à la
gare d'exceptionnel d'enfants de
soignants et aussi aux liens
téléphoniques ou visio avec les
personnes fragiles vous pouvez trouver
une mission sur ce portail dont le lien
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et pour
refermer cette édition spéciale nous
sommes avec julien milon alias sommeil
bonsoir on sera artiste musical et
résidant dans les yvelines vous êtes
avec les a
pour cette liaison vidéo alors vous êtes
actuellement confiné au foyer pour
jeunes travailleurs marcel callo c'est à
versailles où vous résidez comment ça se
passe déjà le confinement pour vous on
nous ça se passe plutôt bien parce que
pour l'instant on est confiné dans notre
studio de fortune
on a monté on fait des petites cover on
lance des défis sur instagram et voilà
bah on s'occupe avec ça finalement on
passe du temps sur les réseaux sociaux
et pour les téléspectateurs de tv 78
dans votre studio de fortune vous avez
préparé une petite pause musicale pour
terminer la journée un petit morceau
qu'est ce que vous allez nous proposer
on a composé gretar voilà c'est un
morceau que j'ai écrit pour l'album qui
va arriver
qui parle de justice sociale de
mouvements sociaux de l'écologie aussi
donc voilà c'est très d'actualité en ce
moment par rapport au confinement et c
est bien merci la merci julien alias
sommeil pour cet extrait que l'on va
écouter tout de suite on se quitte sur
cet extrait merci d'avoir suivi cette
édition spéciale vous l'a retrouvé en
replay sur notre site internet
restez chez vous et très bon week-end
sur tv 78
et
[Musique]
je vois le temps qui vire à l'orage
j'y vois souvent de glorieux présage
mais quand les gens descendent dans la
rue
personne
le matin venir
j'ai mon combat et j'ai ma bannière
je porte la croix mais à ma manière
j'assume mes choix j'en suis fier
importe qu'on soit au même point qui m
[Musique]
je marche marche je mets tout jeu crise
mon prochain
grâce au site
dans une heure sempiternel
il engage un gros tempo mon père
hongrie aussi et on garde espoir
m
il faut être jeune pour encore y croire
[Musique]
mais quand l'argent muraguri eu
je ferai la loi tue n'écoutera plus
[Musique]
[Rires]
oui
[Musique]
la terre est plate mais le monde a faim
la voix le clac et les enfants dansent
quiconque a peur d'être éclaboussés
[Musique]
n'a pas sa place sur ce graphe wallier
laisse moins très laisse-moi respirer
l'âme est belle je veux
qui
oh
quiconque a peur d'être éclaboussés
n'a pas sa place sur ce grand voilier
[Musique]
- être laisse-moi respire
et
[Musique]
où
une chose dont je ne
l'amour
tassetto
[Musique]